F you Le James you're a coward you're a
spineless coward and you're a so
this guy UFC Legend Colby Covington he
saw the video of LeBron James sitting
for the national anthem and he ain't
having it if you hate America so much
and and you don't like this country that
gave you a billion dollars leave it or
come deal with me you go to China go to
go to these sweat shops that you employ
all these laborers and use these women
and pay him Pennies on the dollar to
make your Millions you L Dr James you're
a coward you're a spineless coward and
you're a
I want to get that guy on the show like
I don't know any I don't really care
about UFC or anything but anyone that
dresses like that the indoor sunglasses
you're a
can I also tell you something
about LeBron James I'm not a I'm just
not a fan like I'm not a fan I'm not a
fan of the NBA anymore I know there's
this 7 foot5 guy you want me to watch
what's his name woma Halo or something
wimy Wim and yamba all right I get it
like you know that's fine but like I
just I've just had it with that you know
I watch my old games but LeBron James
I'm playing basketball again even his
sneakers they're too bulky they're just
too bulky get yourself a oldfashioned
pair of Air Jordans you're going to be
happier I mean what is going on here
everyone in that Stadium standing up
hand over heart honoring America as one
should do even if you think she is
imperfect which she is but she's pretty
damn good he just walks in and sits down
and this has been consistent with LeBron
James kneeling for the national anthem
sitting for the national anthem all of
the BLM nonsense um it's not
good